it's horrific that it happened at all
wherever it
happened and um there will you know
cross-reading across the country will be
communities
really really upset and worried uh about
this united
in their grief and all of our thoughts
are
with those that have have lost someone
in this
of course when it comes to politics you
might be working on different issues but
i imagine when something like this
happens you might want to
work with the government on the next
steps in this process what will you be
doing um
as part of the labour party to help move
this forward to a positive conclusion
and
bring you about justice it's very
important that the investigation runs
its course
but i will want to work with the
government in response to this
to look at whether there's lessons that
can be learned where there needs to be
changes to the law
but i think as a constructive opposition
i will want to speak to the prime
minister
to discuss how together we can improve
the response
learn from this the investigation must
be completed but of course
this is not a time for party politics we
heard from neil basu earlier
saying his statement the threat level is
remaining at the same level as it was
before um this happened should that
provide some form of reassurance to the
wider public
well we'll have to look at that and i
want to talk to the prime minister
about it but at the moment investigation
has to
take its course but i think it's
incumbent all of us
to pull together in response to this on
a cross-party basis
you said you haven't spoken to do you
have plans to speak you think you'll be
speaking to the prime minister over the
coming days about this
i will want to speak to the prime
minister about this to offer my
constructive support for any proposals
that the government might
bring forward this is not a time for
party politics this is a time to
recognize
the grief of those that have lost loved
ones
the grief of reading and the nation and
to pull together
and just a final message you mentioned
the people reading up just a final
message to the people of reading who
many of them will never have even
imagined something like this could
happen
in their town in their community my
message
to them is that we understand we feel
the grief we thank our responders the
nhs and the police
yet again what we see is is the horror
of this incident and against it
the heroism if you like of those that
respond to it
but our hearts and thoughts are with the
families and friends in particular the
communities across reading
and i'm sure i'm speaking on behalf the
whole country when i say that